JENNY BROWN: Hi, I'm Jenny.
And today, I'd like
to show you how
to use the Apigee
adapter for Envoy
together with a service mesh to
integrate Envoy-based services
into your Apigee environment.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In this demo, I'll show
you how to use Envoy
to protect a microservice.
I'll add an Envoy
facade on it, which
is configured to talk to the
Apigee adapter for Envoy.
Let's dive in.
I have a Kubernetes cluster that
has a few applications running.
The one we'll focus
on for this demo
is the microservice
called Orders.
By default, there
is no restriction
on who can access
this microservice.
Let me demonstrate that by
accessing it as a consumer.
To simulate a consumer,
I have a cURL application
running in Client.
Once I am logged into
the client application,
I will access the
Orders microservice.
Based on this result,
I was able to access it
without passing through
any security credentials.
Now, let me walk you through
how you can enforce a security
policy so that a consumer
must use credentials
within a service mesh.
To do that, I'll
enable an Envoy filter.
I've created a file that
describes all the security
policies I want to enforce
on the Orders microservice.
For instance, I'm
enforcing a policy
that requests must go
through the Apigee adapter.
I'm now applying this
policy via the filter.
Now, I'm going to access the
Orders microservice again
like I did before.
This time I got an error of
403 forbidden because I didn't
have a security credential.
Let's fix that.
We'll do this through the
API products in Apigee.
I've already created
an Orders API product,
which is bound to the endpoint
orders running on port 8080.
I've also created
an application that
allows me to access the
credentials for the Orders
microservice.
Let's access the Orders
microservice again,
this time with the API key.
I'm using an API key.
But you could also use
an access token instead.
Success!
I was able to access
the microservice.
Through all these
interactions, analytics
are being collected
and transmitted
to the Apigee control panel.
Looking at the API
metrics here, you'll
notice that the
Orders microservice is
getting requests, and I
can view the data for that.
This is how you can use the
Apigee adapter for Envoy
to enforce policies for
any service that's using
Envoy within a service mesh.
If you found this demo
helpful, check out
our introductory Apigee
adapter for Envoy video linked
in the description below.
And for more information like
code labs and blog posts,
check out these links.
Thanks for watching.